to many people fitness and performance
simply means being really strong or
maybe being able to run long distances
but this isn't fitness this is simply
being highly capable at a single task
this doesn't prepare you for all the
challenges life will throw at you and it
doesn't develop your body and mind in a
truly comprehensive and well-rounded
manner it won't undo the significant
damage caused by decades of sitting in
the chair mildly stressed it's time to
rethink what training can mean if you're
professional athletes then I fully
understand that sprinting lifting
weights swimming diving or another sport
is your career and your passion you have
a genuine shot at being the very best in
the world and therefore all your efforts
should be focused on that one thing but
for everyone else if the goal of
training is to improve quality of life
and physical and mental performance
specialization doesn't make any sense at
least not to me you tend to see this
most often with weightlifting people
obsess over their benchpress deadlift
and squat one rep maxes they push
themselves harder and harder further and
further why so they can be the best at
their gym or the best on an online forum
meanwhile they might completely ignore
their mobility or their ability to focus
for long periods nagging pains or their
endurance they even forget other aspects
of strength such as rotational strength
or straight arm strength there comes a
certain point where you see diminishing
returns
being able to benchpress a lot of weight
will have direct benefits on your daily
life and give you a sense of
accomplishment but does being able to
bench 150 kilograms instead of 140
kilograms have the same major benefits
why dedicate all of your efforts to that
one singular goal that tiny improvement
when so many other aspects of your
physical and mental performance could
benefit by being brought up to the same
level of course it's not just weight
lifters who fall foul of this
calisthenics athletes will often obsess
over their next skill without thinking
about endurance endurance athletes will
often run huge distances without
thinking what it's doing to their body
many other people will simply pick a
sport and focus on that be it dance bit
park or beach soccer some sports
inherently develop more well-rounded
individuals owing to a higher number of
techniques and various challenges dance
and martial arts come to mind but no
single activity will test you in
anything close to your full range of
abilities I'm not saying you shouldn't
aim to get better you should always
strive to be better if you
left 140 kilograms then absolutely you
should still aim for that hundred and
fifty but I'd rather be stronger than
eighty percent of people and faster than
eighty percent of people rather than
stronger than ninety percent of people
and slower than fifty what's more is
that these abilities have cross over and
as you improve them you'll see they
naturally reinforce one another as for
why so few people even consider training
their brains as well as their bodies
that's an even bigger mystery to me
brain training would have the most a
direct and immediate impact on our daily
lives our relationships our careers and
even our ability to train efficiently
learning is a form of training and
through brain plasticity we now know
that the brain can grow and change shape
in response to specific training to
tools like meditation and dual n-back
we'll bulk up specific brain networks
just like particular moves will develop
certain muscles in the gym more can be
trained to your reflexes eyesight pretty
much anything you need these things no
less than you need to be able to squat
to 200 kilograms or run an ultra
marathon and in fact as he developed
yourself in every area you give yourself
more options in any situation you become
slightly better at anything to change
your life you need to develop yourself
don't ask what you need to do to get
there ask who you need to become this
kind of total training will make us more
proficient in sports and skills it'll
make us more formidable in a fight it
will provide us with more varied and
versatile abilities it'll make us more
knowledgeable patient and compassionate
will help us see new opportunities and
the sheer process of personal growth
will be endlessly rewarding very
challenging and exciting if you train to
become a better version of yourself to
supplement your general performance and
to complement your lifestyle then surely
it makes sense to bring every facet of
your physical and mental performance up
to the highest possible level in the
given time not just to pick one and call
that training imagine what it would feel
like to be stronger more energetic
smarter more focused more mobile more
alert more resilient more creative more
agile more knowledgeable all at once
imagine what we could become thanks for
watching this guy's I hope you enjoyed
it also I got a new camera not sure if
you noticed but I was kind of loving it
a huge thank you to everyone on patreon
who made that possible and if you want
to get involved and join the Facebook
group you'll find the link in the
description down below likewise if you
enjoy this philosophical whole-brain
body approach
to training then you might enjoy my
ebook and training program super
functional training there's a link in
the description down below and it's on
discount right now whilst we're all
stuck in lockdown or while service are
any ways including yours truly thanks
again for watching team hope you're all
safe and healthy and I'll catch you next
time bye for now
you